we'd like to now calculate the angular
momentum about an axis of rotation of a
symmetric object like a ring so here's
our axis of rotation we're gonna have
Omega pointing up that means Omega Z Z
will be positive because that's going to
be our K hat axis and this is a ring of
mass m and radius R so here's our radius
now and we're gonna choose a point
that's some lies somewhere on the
symmetry axis of the ring and the object
is rotating about that symmetry axis so
it's passing through the center of mass
now we've already the way we'll do this
is we'll divide our ring up into pairs
of symmetric objects so we have an M
here and a little Delta M there and
we're going to calculate the angular
momentum first of that pair well we've
already made that calculation that the
angular momentum about S of the pair is
twice the mass of each object that's the
mass of the pair times R squared and it
points in the Omega direction and so to
get the angular momentum of the Ring
we'll just sum up a set of symmetric
pairs until we expand out over the
entire ring and so L of the ring about s
is just the sum over the pairs of the
mass of the pair times R squared Omega
and R squared and Omega are all
constants the total mass of the ring is
just the sum over the pairs of the mass
of the pair and that's the total mass M
of the ring and so what we get is an R
squared Omega L of the ring s this is
the moment of inertia about the axis for
the ring because all the mass is
distributed a distance R away and so we
see for a continuous symmetric body like
a ring
again because it's symmetric the angular
momentum only has a component along the
axis of rotation now what if we had a an
extended symmetric object and let's see
if I can possibly draw something like
that so we'll draw a pear-shaped object
what is the moment of inertia of this
pear-shaped object which is intended to
be symmetric about the z axis well I can
think of that pear-shaped object as
consisting of a ring and it's a solid
object this is a solid symmetric object
and then inside the ring is just more
rings so the whole disk here is just a
superposition of rings and so the moment
of inertia so the angular momentum of
just this disk is the moment of the disk
about the axis and now I'll just add
more disks that are symmetric and so by
exactly the same calculation as I have
here the moment of this symmetric object
is just the moment of inertia is more
complicated for this object and it
points in the Omega direction so again
in conclusion a symmetric object about
the axis of rotation only has a
component of L pointing in the direction
of Omega the constant of proportionality
between the angular momentum and the
angular velocity is the moment of
inertia about that acts
axis this we need to calculate for each
symmetric object